but who knows these days huh I don't
know who's checked out oh yeah I'd done
this I'm just stupid we need to go out
side to the werewolf or whatever the
[ __ ] he never shows Alfred I don't know
what's up with I do you know without
that maybe I'll show himself in the
enemy like hey what's up
that's what I'm hoping for all right let
me kiss your bike I'm sorry this is like
castrating you but a man's gotta do what
a man's gotta do my brother's doing a
little a huh oh [ __ ] sorry
let me go laddering style on this [ __ ]
it's like lantern normal or creepy uh we
need to go to the blacksmith isn't here
is that a zit yes it is cool you know
what cool better this whatever this is
called I got a lot of comments but I
still don't remember because everyone
kept saying different things I don't
know these things
yeah yeah yeah then that [ __ ] hmm
now I need something to bend them huh
aah what is wrong with this oh thank you
okay they don't look bent at all honest
okay they are so that's how you lock
picker yes it it paired yes it a shot
spice okay
well back to the house mayor's house be
bigger are you brothers watching The
Walking we haven't done here yeah no I
guess we're going there later
we was watching the walk in bed I don't
know why but when people say the mayor's
house I think of the governor and walk
in that the more you know you're welcome
you're [ __ ] welcome I'm just worried
that this game is like gonna bill up
tension for like this huge jump scare
some stupid [ __ ] like that that would
have been perfect right ice snot all
over them all right when I've done it
and that's a chattering hair as books
Hades huh
why I cannot only read them I can throw
them at [ __ ] that's kind of cool
well I would assume I need something in
here that's another one Automator oh
it's like oh yeah I read about this the
Greeks used to do it Oh GDS filled
strikes again
see I'm not so ignorant and dumb as
every one thing huh
finally we get the map about friction
time is there anything else we'll get in
here there has to be a key a note hello
friend of OTT we are play dead bond here
that we finally got the man who thought
he would ever a plan
he had a keel and a bat a head tag a
metallic ID okay open that entereth
temple IRA thought I know where the
temple area is don't want to Matt
approach us I found a way to enter as
it's securely sealed above the door
there is a site that says none we should
also like to inform you that the analyst
is here the catalyst you can proceed the
final ceremony I will make sense make
sure that the term stays in the temple
and doesn't doesn't your in our plans
cool
and we have that Gabrus we have so many
things is it all right watch sorry did I
scare you you scaredy cats bros I'm just
kidding your look you look a little you
look a little pale there did I really
have scare you it's getting you look
Browns like I'm like a brownie does that
sound weird to say I felt like I can't
say some things on the internet you know
wow
y'all I am i right can't say Yolo either
[ __ ] alright well we're gonna go to that
place while your party okay
I'm hoping I'm hoping it's here
because it is like the only place that I
know of that uh needs a key I think
alright press hold hold hold your horses
hold your horse that hold them yes yeah
ah die feels good oh I could have
literally just climbed over that [ __ ]
seriously gone through all that effort
to pick lock and ah well I guess we
found some information on what we're
doing and now I can enjoy this pill shed
I'm too short
[ __ ] well I gotta move in at least
Laluna Linoone I'm multi bellissima c3
see oh oh this is new territory bros I
don't like this
it could be anyone behind me sorry sorry
I don't need to do it
I'm just kidding I'm just being it owl I
know you're watching me not in the mood
right now
okay I'm just gonna follow this route oh
this is giving me aa
is giving fits the goose bumps the goose
bumps whoa creepy eyes really creepy I
hate small cabins in the woods they
creep kids
I got a potato no [ __ ] me in the ass it
sounded very close huh I guess he likes
potatoes okay
Vlad me pants take the potatoes I don't
know if I want the potatoes what
I think we're safe bro
what he's gotta be really [ __ ] quiet
I do not like this okay don't worry I
know exactly what I'm doing
parley with bumpers on all right I'm
running I'm running I'm running
like this for judges that looks fun oh
that's the door that we need to uh open
[ __ ] Greek mythology man I don't I'm
not okay with that
what is this a stone pillar with a whole
lot in on one all right we need some way
to open this
I don't have the lock I guess we gotta
go back and cook some [ __ ] not drugs
okay so it says here we need grinded
barley with the recipes I would Oh mint
Clearwater and ashes we have ashes we
have mint I think we can get clear water
from the kitchen and I guess we can
grind the barley there too as well so
yeah brothers we go and we going back to
the mayor's house I just hope I don't
get [ __ ] on the way there wet what in
my town [ __ ] I don't don't
ain't got no werewolves in my belly and
got nowhere balls and nitrous and got
nowhere balls in my benches because we
[ __ ] werewolf wenches [ __ ] this
painting has supper head round are there
it and there's a double paw here we're
gonna go into the kitchen we gotta take
this bottle can't believe at it and see
a nice huh ah we're gonna get some
mortar but it isn't in our hand we have
a trapped I don't know what they call in
English girl I just wanna go and rock
your world
come on baby let's get naked have some
fun let's get going buddy all night long
ooh baby cow you're the one for me baby
girl could you just come with me we can
go outside and be on your dad's
brand-new
so you can see best song ever ten out of
ten okay let's see what we're doing here
oh this is what we need this is one of
those things that used to crush
I'm pretty [ __ ] sure that was in the
wind why would I hope that was the what
hello oh this is not down with this [ __ ]
okay well why do i why do I put this
closing the door for that [ __ ]
oh here we are right yeah that's how you
cook - it's an empty ball cool uh-huh
which order ah Shh
I need water uh there's water by the
fountain do you bros remember oh oh
there's someone out here there's someone
out there okay okay I'm going I'm going
we're going to get water drink that [ __ ]
I feel like my senses are getting high -
what the [ __ ] am i an avatar I felt like
I'm blue and shed explain this ball shut
this one
[ __ ] the lights up or well well is that
no what is going on this is pretty
[ __ ] weird [ __ ] man am i a little
faster
ah what is that sound
ah I'm taking Lantern now I don't give a
sh a okay I don't know that's s Redshaw
Ches
I don't know about it whatever happens
here I want you to know that I love you
and no [ __ ] job [ __ ] it stay says it's a
woman or a man I'm seeing ghosts [ __ ]
drugs man
what am i writing down I show a vision
of a man hiding something at that it
looks like a hint something what did
that crazy [ __ ] hid hide what a
cylindrical explosion on the bottom a
plate I found at the theater the fact of
the drink wore off that was all right
wait no the drugs ah ah no I need that
[ __ ] I need a brittle I need it hey more
ah I feel sick
I've got like a brat what do I do now
okay technically speaking now what are
you least [ __ ] with a lantern or lamp
out of that perspective or the one who's
sucking your ass I think you're [ __ ]
with both honestly
yep I am [ __ ] with Bo let's go with this
okay lantern you want lantern you want
flashlight what what's that lantern all
right
flashlight all right flashlight it is
ah don't [ __ ] with me stairs alright I
hope this is gonna work for us
I hope to god this is gonna work uh huh
okay do I got any greek bros out there
huh look at that hey why you're no oven
I don't have any lighter fluid I have
matches though [ __ ]
so in the next episode we're going to go
here it's probably going to be the final
one